we'll kick
I'm John Mills on the bottom of all my
slides
they'll be my twitter handle hashtag
next-gen async just so you if you want
to tweet something positive if you want
to be something negative then go ahead
and put my outside it's fine I don't
care okay next-gen async patterns and
JavaScript is what we're going to talk
about it should I didn't want to put in
JavaScript at the bottom because it got
too long and too wordy so but this is
gonna JavaScript and kind of like I said
before we're I'm gonna kind of take a
stroll through I'm and tie them all
together but we'll start with callbacks
alright callbacks is how many of you
write callbacks today okay some of you
are lying how how many of you are
morally opposed to hand raising okay
right so just so I know right now the
who's not gonna raise their hand right
so javascript is isn't a synchronous
language there's a lot of stuff that it
does they it'll call you back
later which is where callbacks come from
right so we end up writing a lot of code
that looks like this and this code is
gross and I don't know because it's you
know we we call it Christmas tree code
have you heard that phrase before
because it gets you get in there
and there's there's a lot of issues with
this and I'm not gonna go into all of
them because this is old generation
right we're gonna talk about next
generation so this is the problem we're
trying to solve and how many of you have
ever had undefined is not a function as
an error right javascript has errors
where you get thrown errors especially
if you're in strict mode you will get
errors all over the place and callbacks
are very very bad at error handling
right and there's unfortunately there's
like three or four different ways that
that people handle errors different
patterns I'm a big fan of the nude style
because I'm a node developer where so up
here I've got function air
and then the returned right and then you
have to inside your function you've got
a tests to see if there's an error and
then you can go on and do stuff and it
just took that one function that kind of
was gross and it makes it even grosser
and if I J so we want to fix this this
is not what we want to do the async way
this works is kind of gross - this is
so this is from the node side but
you can imagine this being on the rest
side - this is gross and it's very
difficult to see what's going on and if
errors occur you've got to test them
inside everything it's gross and here's
here's the problem and this is the
problem we're ultimately trying to solve
by the end of this talk we start there
we don't write this all at once we start
like this right I've got a manga client
connect I'm opening a collection and
then I close it I'm gonna try it and
it's gonna work and it's great then I'm
gonna add the next line of code I'm
gonna do a find one I'm gonna go for a
look for a book and then I'm gonna do
something with the results I now have a
problem this my DB closed down at the
bottom
now I'm getting Irish thrown but I'm not
catching any errors right if I'm not
Testament here so the problem we have is
that as we start to write code we don't
get to have it work in a sequential way
all right some of you who are from the
dotnet background most of you raise your
hand that you are dotnet developers
you're used to like this sequential way
of writing code and you could stick
things in the middle and everything
still works and JavaScript doesn't
necessarily work that way so that's the
problem we're trying to solve as we kind
of get through this whole thing all
right
promises our step where I spend just a
couple minutes on promises promises have
been around for a little while the
different promise frameworks how many of
you have used a promise framework in the
past okay so this almost all of you so
this would be kind of an old hat but
we'll click through it because it leads
to where we're going
promises ultimately serve two purposes
the first purpose they serve is in a
callback situation you have incoming and
out
showing things inside the same function
call right I'm calling a function and
I'm sending in and I'm sending in
something that's going to come out and
that's weird right so what a promise
does is just separate your incoming from
your hunger that's like half of what
promises serve that's so there you go
because then we add the dot done in
between and so what a promise looks like
I just have a request that basically you
see a call back there and it called my
call back with my error and I return a
value well that's cool a promise
basically looks like this so a promise
is an object so think of a promise as a
thing and and so I'm gonna return any
promise notice call back doesn't exist
anymore right I'm not passing in the
callback we now have this thing called a
resolve which essentially is the
callback right I mean that's what it is
just separate it up no so right I'm
gonna call resolve and then return the
value so this is promise face which if
you remember this looks so much better
than the last one did right because the
last one looked like this the promised
place one that looks like this it really
doesn't look that much better does it
right but at least it's separated right
so I've got my person URL and then we do
something else don't worry I'm not gonna
end there like we'll we'll make it look
right but but this is I walk into client
sites and I pull up their code and
they're using promises and they're using
promises like this you might as well
just be doing callbacks okay so then
right now one of our errors because the
dot then only handles kind of thing this
is the other thing that promises will do
for you the other thing promises are
going to do for you is separate errors
from success right right now we've got
function error and then person that was
the callback the nude style callback way
what we're going to do is actually
separate our errors from our successes
so in the native ESX promises you
actually have kept two functions right
you can have the resolved
and you can have the reject which is
great because of now I can just call
reject instead of resolve so in our new
promise we've added this reject keyword
here and I've got resolved and then when
something bad happens I can just reject
it and then I'm gonna call the reject
and so what that looks like now here
I've got my if err else I'm gonna do
something now in the cool new promised
way boom function error I just now have
two functions right I don't have to have
my if errors anymore it's kind of do it
like this all right that's cool
ish but then you can get into named
functions which is where you should be
by the way regardless of anything else
you do everything should be named
functions no anonymous functions because
does this code look better than the code
I had up there before much right I just
it's the same thing I'm just calling
name functions okay
so then so I had two functions you can
also do dot catch so promises introduced
this thing called catch so I have then
or not catch and now I fully separated
everything from get greeting to handle
error everything's all split out and
this this actually looks like halfway
decent code would you agree this is much
better than what we had before the other
thing to remember promises are things
remember it earlier I said promise is
essentially an object from right I mean
it's an object that you hand around that
just buries your callback underneath for
you so what you can do here might get
greeting function calls the requests and
then does the dot done well this dot n
can actually I can just return my
request and then called dot n so now I
have this request personally URL then
get greeting then send greeting boom
change it's beautiful it's nice it's
simple
great
this is not necessarily new i included a
new because es6 promises are now a thing
but if you are you doing angular using
dollar cue or I mean there's promise
frameworks that have been out there for
a while so promises may not be super
exciting but we have to at least talk
about them because we're now gonna talk
about generators how many of you use
generators today that is the right yeah
I like your answer that was very naughty
I don't know maybe okay this is the
right answer cuz
hopefully this conversation might be a
little mind-blowing for you so check
this out this is a generator function
generator functions are available in es6
in my opinion generators are the most
powerful es6 feature available how many
of you have been to an es6 talk I have
not heard generators mentioned at all
like most of you because the most es6
talks don't talk about generators I'll
explain over the course of this
conversation I'll explain to you why I
find them to be very powerful okay so
this is a generator function the star
doesn't matter where you put it as long
as it's one of those two spots this is
correct and by correct I mean somebody
has said this is the way they like it
and everybody just kind of went along
with it this star goes by the function
generators break the concept of a when
you call a function the function runs
through the completion and then hands
back a results right you either return
or you terminate or something
generators yield a value back so I call
the function yields a value then it
waits until it is reassured not you know
like pokes right hey give me the next
value right so I'm gonna we're gonna
spend a couple minutes I'm just gonna
talk through generators and then we'll
get to why we're talking about them in
an async talk all right you execute a
generator kind of the same way you
execute a function right
so I've got my a generator function VAR
caller equals Jenny so let's kind of
talk through a generator function
function generator console dot log I'm
working yield message down here at the
bottom of our caller equals Jen I have
not yet done this console dot log so
this when this is executed console that
log has not run yet just so this is I do
this thing called Jen next give me the
next thing and then all of a sudden all
this stuff starts happening so message
is returned back so console dot log at
this point is going to print message and
then do stuff it doesn't do stuff yet
right it stops right there at the yield
and that's not really true when I say
message is returned and actually is it
gonna return something that looks like
this it's gonna return an object has a
value and whether or not it's complete
right so value is message done boss what
I call Jen dot next again now I'm gonna
get next message see where that comes
from I yield next message is the next
thing so and then done is still false
there's no more yields done is still
false okay I call Jen dot next one more
time and now I get a value of undefined
and done it's true this is a generator
right so we're gonna talk about
generators in async this is a generator
this is essentially what it is and you
can kind of start to get an inkling of
how this works because it stops and it
waits for results come back so that
gives you a kind of a clue of what's
going on but before I do there let me
talk about generators in one other
context and then it'll all start to make
sense so let's build a pie inter-rater
so ultimately generators are our
iterators right would you soon dot next
dot max dot next so we're gonna build a
pie in a rater and I don't mean this
kind of pie we're gonna do like the
number pie but I don't know if you know
this they're the same just mirrored
that's kind of weird I just discovered
this so but we're gonna build a pie etta
rater so you can kind of see what's
going on
all right now I lie for the purposes of
a fitting code on a slide I'm just
hard-coding 3.1415 right there are a few
more numbers and PI after that but I'm
going to stop at 5 because nobody cares
you want that okay this is your picture
opportunity for this slide just so that
you can prove later that this actually
does what now everybody's taking a
picture okay okay okay okay so now now
really the cool thing about a generator
is it's just a function and I could put
all kinds of stuff in here that would
manage memory and because when I get to
like the 7 billionth digit in PI I don't
want to have to have remembered the
other thing so I can build me I can do
all kinds of cool stuff in here but it's
not the purpose of this talk so we're
moving on so then ultimately I can just
do next X X X next and I get this 3.1415
and then value undefined done is true
that's a little gross right we don't
really like that and the reason why
value undefined is there is because the
function terminates there and it sends
back undefined question how else do you
end a function nobody knows I return I
have to see it wasn't a trick question
it's very straightforward
right so I'm going to return 9 what do
you think is gonna print out it's not a
trick question
don't worry yeah yeah yeah so I'm gonna
get value 9 done is true that's great
this is significantly less gross so dun
dun dun dun dun right so this is how
kind of that iterator idea works
this is gross all right we don't like
that that's kind of ugly
so es6 also has this other very cool
feature called the for of loop how many
of you have used the four of loop before
yeah
four of is awesome did you know four of
will automatically iterate over a
generator that makes it kind of cool so
I can just do this for let I of Pi
taught so long guy and they will
automatically loop over your generator
that's kind of neat and they'll print
3.1415 is that what you would have
guessed it would have printed no you're
honest what happened to the nine right
so I introduced this whole concept of
return and then I just like made it go
away right because ultimately the LAT is
well next I've done does not equal true
Donnan equals true so I introduced
return and then I took it back away from
you I'm just mean like that right okay
so right but ultimately that's that's
most of the generator where generators
start to become interesting for what
we're talking about is it introduces
this level of conversation back and
forth between the generator function and
the caller function so I have a
generator function called let's talk
it's going to yield back a question what
is your name it's going to accept a
result of that and stick it in a
variable and then it's gonna yield back
a greeting and here's how you would call
that right so converse equals let's talk
converse not next dot value is going to
be this what is your name right then
when I do converse that next again I am
going to send in a value I'm gonna send
in John and then it's gonna spit out a
value of hello jump right so I can send
values into generators I can pull values
out of generators that's all very cool
the other very cool thing about this
that makes this very compelling for
first synchronous code or for
asynchronous code
is how he handles errors because this is
all synchronous there's no callbacks
here right have you seen a single
callback since we started talking about
generators no no callbacks which means
nothing is running after so if I throw
because notice right I had a number and
a number number number and then I had
this character it's not a character it's
actually a string because that's the way
JavaScript is but if I throw I can just
wrap the whole thing in a try-catch
block I don't see very many try-catch
blocks a lot of times in JavaScript
because everything's asynchronous and
they don't do you any good right but I
can wrap everything on a try-catch block
and when it gets thrown I can catch it
and it's great
imagine if you could wrap a try-catch
block around all of your Ajax calls and
like catch errors that's like craziness
okay so that's great for an iterator oh
one more thing to my ears okay so I can
catch but the other thing I can do is I
can throw errors in so remember my my
poly iterator what remember I've got
memory management I've got all this
stuff going on in the iterator if
something happens outside I want to be
able to do some clean up inside my
iterator right and so I can actually do
it err a tour dot throw and it'll catch
so like say I'm right here I'm waiting
right here it'll get a throw and I'll
pop down into the catch and that's cool
so then my iterator can clean itself up
it's just kind of neat or in this case
when we get there it can do some other
things okay so that's cool too a errors
all right up until now we have the
generator is the iterator and the
calling function is doing the work a
sync happens when we flip it over what
if the main function is a generator that
yields out two things
and then weights that's where this
becomes very interesting so let's let's
look at an example of this all right so
I've got a whole bunch of code here and
I'm not really gonna talk through all of
it but essentially what happens is I'm
calling a person service I'm getting a
name that I'm calling the greeting
service with the name and then I which
gives me my greeting back okay notice
one thing right here look look at how
this I'm making two different calls to
two different services and notice
there's no indentation whatsoever like
that's this is where we're going but I'm
gonna try it I'm gonna bend your brain
for just a second and then I'll make it
a little calmer okay when this thing
works we start with me
notice main is a generator function I
create an instance of my main and then I
call next when I call next what happens
is that it executes this make request
make requests calls my HTTP call which
does this head timeout okay now what
happens when I execute the set timeout
everything else falls through right so
where's my main one that set timeout is
called my set timeout my main is gonna
stop right there
halt all function this can wait and then
it's gonna go out it's gonna come back
it's going to return my my greeting and
all of that if I don't call my set if I
don't have a set timeout there like if
I'm just playing around with it I don't
stick the set timer this is why I'm
calling it out is the it dot next
happens before the yield and everything
breaks right so you've got to have this
set timeout to make this work okay so
I've got my yield back
then when the work hall comes back my
issues but it calls not next and when
I've got next is called with the
response
now result 1 equals whatever came back
in that response it parses the name out
then it calls the greeting service this
is a sequential series of calls even
though I'm calling out to other things
this is like fundamentally different
than how we have done asynchronous up
till now just make sense okay kinda all
right so this like let's try to make
this just a little bit easier there is a
thing a package called Co who's used Co
before okay nobody that's awesome that's
because you're in the right place so Co
is a package that's designed to be used
with generators which is great and I
love it because it's going to take all
of this gross --mess everybody follow
this anybody not follow this cuz now is
the time to ask a question oh you did
follow it I've got time we can talk
about it okay Wow okay so hold on let me
back up for just a second and kind of
touch on this again not too much but
just again because next is what iterates
right the next is the thing that makes
this thing happen so next kicks the
whole thing off but because it is
available in the public scope or not the
public zone but it's in the you know
it's available to everything when my
callback comes back it is available in
down inside the function and so because
it is available down inside the function
I can call next from way up here I don't
have to call it next it next it next
right there I mean it's it's just a func
it's just an object right it's just a
thing
can coliform anywhere so because it's
available I can embed it in this
callback here because of closures and
blah blah blah and all that stuff and
then kind of iterate through a little
bit does that make sense okay hold on
all right so that's kind of how that
goes
so what Coe is gonna do for us is make
this easier
so Coe is promise based and so this is
why we talked about promises for just a
little bit so what happens is I've got
this what we've had up so now I've got
make requests and then I've got my my
HTTP call which basically is just a set
timeout blah blah blah I can rewrite all
this stuff as a promise and the way that
works is this so I'm gonna pull go in
and you can pull go in however you pull
you know this is a node example so it's
there but you know if you make ko
available by a script tag in your
browser or what I doesn't matter however
you I do it or modules you know import
ko then I take my HTTP call that did
look like this and I just wrap
everything in a promise so a new promise
set timeout and then I resolve my
promise with this so stay in a promise
no surprise nothing's new nothing's
different here that's all then I wrap ko
ko' wraps around my generator and it
will unpack all my promises for me which
is super awesome because so function
main requests this this request call
right here is actually so I didn't
change the name of it but I just call
HTTP call directly it's going to return
a promise it's gonna resolve this thing
and KO will actually unpack that for me
pull out the values and then drop it
into
my result one which is great and then
move on to the next thing and move on to
the next thing you move on to the next
thing and now I have very sequential
code
what about errors right so how many of
you have had to nest breast calls before
right you got one call you've got
another call even right so a lot of you
what happens with when one errors right
then you've got to write code to clean
that up and you've got one code to clean
that up and one code to clean that up
in Co or we're using generators I can
just try catch done I can wrap the whole
big thing in a try-catch block and be
done because what's going to happen is
if I throw an error we're up in the
request can we throw an error here then
it drops down to my catch if if there
are an air here drops down in my catch
because I'm waiting it's all just a sink
okay it's all not you think it's all
just synchronous stuff so generators
take this idea of asynchronous code and
shuffle you back into just plain
synchronous up and down how many like
the way this looks better some of you
some of you aren't sure okay now is your
opportunity because I built in a lot of
time to like have conversations but now
is your opportunity to say wait a second
timeout I have questions and if I will
tell you this if you have a question
like seven other people in the room have
a question too right so don't be afraid
to like spit it out so what of this
isn't quite clicking nothing everybody's
clear all right
yes do up if I take this piece of code
can I make a promise out of it as well
say that water does Co return a promise
yes and which is awesome and I don't
have the the closing parenthesis so that
probably doesn't help this is what I get
for copying and pasting my code code
does return a promise and so you can put
a dot catch on the end that'll even kind
of bubble up even further if you have
any errors and that all of that kind of
stuff happens so generators are
available in almost everything so Chrome
has them Firefox has them node has them
it's all there right now and so you can
go ahead and use you can use this right
now what we kind of sometimes want to do
is now move out
- ASA Kuwait we're talking about a
single way for just a couple of minutes
yep the generator function okay so so
this is because the answer is yes okay
so the question is our generators
available in the browsers right and the
answer is yes the problem with that is
that it's available in the latest
browsers how many of you familiar with
kanga acts Oh
sweet I'm gonna show you something I
don't have this up already
oh where is it
hold on but this is a good opportunity
to teach you guys can Dex except I don't
have Wi-Fi on which is super less than
awesome and so I'm not gonna teach you
King of X because my wife I won't even
like try to connect that's less than
cool ok so there's there's a website you
can google it call here let me come down
here put it out of slide real quick so
go to Kenya X dot github I yes see I
couldn't join Wi-Fi um
Kenya exile github do and what Kenya X
dot github I owe is is the compatibility
table for all of es6 and es7 and yes
next and all of the features that are
available to you and what Kenya X will
do for you that is the weirdest thing
like okay I'm not even going to joke no
I know I can't connect so so generators
are available right now in all the
latest browsers the problem with that is
how many of you have to support like IE
10 or IE 9 right so they're not
available there but babel who uses babel
oh yes so some of you babble is what's
the best way to describe babble babble I
like to call babble a compiler because
babble calls itself a compiler but it
just so I can fit in with the cool
javascript crowd it's a transpiler that
will take all your es6 code although
generators and all the stuff and will
convert it down to es 5 and generators
ultimately a promise based underneath if
you look at what the code anyway so go
out here get all that stuff does that
answer your question in a very
long-winded way okay
other questions we hit play again I wish
I had internet to show you that other
questions not generators before I move
because this is can be fairly
mind-bending stuff but hopefully this
looks yes
so right because it because ultimately
in es5 generators don't exist right and
so when you transpile down to es5 the
underpinnings with the code that it's
writing is all promise base and it makes
it kind of gross and ugly which is but
but ultimately yeah but generators are
promise based in general right
especially this because that requests
this request right here is a price to
return a promise if it doesn't return a
promise it doesn't work right that it
has to return a promise and that promise
gets unpacked by KO in this case and it
pulls out the value and just drops the
value in to yield right so if this if
this is what's happening it was
something work it has to be this I
promise I don't refer to work does that
make sense
oh yeah other generator questions you're
starting to get warm up a little bit any
other generator questions no okay so
let's talk wrap everything in a
try-catch block that's all cool okay
async here's here's the struggle with
async how many of you have heard of
async await okay how many of you are
using async await a couple and okay
that's a great question in JavaScript
how many of you are using async await in
JavaScript okay this is just a couple
anything away that's very cool
the problem with a single wait for me
right now is that it is not yet
available it's like true it's okay
because you said you use a single way
and what capacity or how are you using
it so types scripts so it's available in
typescript and then it compiles down the
polyfill for a single a it is is
generators under underneath it and I'll
show you aa here in just a second
bye
and I would have to validate a single
way is only even partially available in
Babel it's not fully baked and Babel and
so this is kind of one of those things
I'm gonna show you and then you can kind
of see it but the reality is it's only
kind of available alright so we had this
Co function right function main result
one result to all of this kind of stuff
a single weight is essentially the same
thing as this which is why I spent a lot
of time kind of on generators because we
kind of talked through that now we have
we're gonna convert this code to a
single weight code are you ready okay
this is code generators that's a single
weight there's really not much
difference right that's the difference
so basically the only difference between
the the generator based thing that I'm
showing you with is you drop go out and
up here instead of code now you have a
sink and it's not a generator function
in March there's an async function still
do all your tries still do all your
caches all of that stuff still kind of
works but now you've got a week instead
of yield right other than that it works
exact the same way so if you write your
code now using code using generators if
you ever want to convert everything over
to async await you want now understand
how it all works right I mean that's
kind of how it works and then we kind of
go through that that's a now anything is
he is next and I can't get to kanga so I
can't show you kind of where it's at and
it's a little ways off it'll be what
would be your best guess if I had to ask
your thoughts when when do you think I
think away it would be generally
available in the white
I probably say six months ish before you
can really yep yep bye for now
start writing everything with Co with
generators and then it all just works
because that stuff is available now
unless you have to support ie ten but if
you're if you're you know the the late
stage II's go ahead and use it use Babel
to trans file and you'll be in really
good shape okay you guys were very light
on the questions and so I'm kind of
through a little early but we can go
back so so here's what I want to do I
can go back and we can kind of talk
through some flow of generators if you
would like to if you have questions we
can talk through some other stuff if you
do not have questions I am not offended
you are freedom to go out this way but
if you do have questions let's talk
through some stuff because I want to
make sure you guys are clear this is
weird this looks not weird this was
weird right so I want to kind of give
you guys the opportunity to really talk
through this
okay so this is a great question so in a
single way it's kind of kind of be the
same thing as Co how am i how am i
executing this right where does this sit
inside of our application that's a great
question because ultimately well let's
go to the async/await one so I have this
function right and I've got main where
does main sit and main would sit so I
would wrap my my service layer is all
async/await so when I call my service
I'm calling an async function and then
it's going to run through all of this
stuff and then it's going to come back
or it's not gonna come back so in that
situation if I there's a couple
different ways to do this and who asks
for about promises right so ultimately
in this situation I might have my
service return a promise I step through
all my async stuff and then when my
acing stuff is all done and resolve the
promise does that make sense if if I
didn't want to do that sometimes you're
just handing stuff off I just call it
and I don't care I'm not worried about
it you're gonna throw an error if
something's broken otherwise we're going
to go back that way so that makes sense
all right what else what other stuff is
kind of percolating that doesn't say yep
Soko is actually a function of execution
so in and of itself so I execute co and
I pass in my generator and it just runs
it so this would be kind of the same
thing that we were just talking about if
I have my service layer I I do you know
book service or this case greeting
service dots send greeting and then that
send greeting function is just a coke
all in it it goes in a desert yeah so
there would be a function around this oh
you mean this yeah I always put one
there I haven't done it without it
because I always did my functions when I
have yeah I think so but now that's
actually a great thing I'm gonna will
try here here in just a couple of
minutes what
okay yep yep so you can just put a star
okay awesome
all right what else what other questions
what else do I need yeah
that's an awesome question it's
completely unrelated to this
conversation but that's fine and we'll
talk about it so so if we are debugging
our JavaScript code it depends on if
your where are you debugging it's sort
of debugging like chrome tools it
depends on if you're transplanting it
depends on where you write your my brain
just went blank what's the thing
you know what I chance filed down what
yes thank you my map files because it'll
it'll pull it back up and you can
actually debug through this if you're
writing yeah if you're writing about
files outside and then your UI can
actually pull I can even debug through
my TS files up at that level if I want
to and so this will little work just the
same way yeah so how many of you do not
debug in Chrome or something Oh Chrome
oh I said how many do not and nobody
raised their hand does that mean
everybody does I double my I double
negated myself yeah okay so great you
guys are all on the right path
definitely definitely debugging Chrome
right your map files get it up there and
it all begin okay any any other
questions okay I'm gonna let you guys go
just a little bit early I am gonna I
will stand here and if you were not
wanting to ask questions in front of the
large group of people that's totally
cool
come and ask me privately if you would
like to and then I will loudly answer
the question for the 17 other people who
were afraid to ask the same question as
we go okay so you guys can go but like I
said come up here and let's talk through
questions if you have them thank you
guys
[Applause]